so I wonder with your films that the
stories you've often told they can often
be very challenging but they're built on
this kind of foundation of myths
biblical tales are very like with Black
Swan a well-known story which is then
contemporized so do you think about this
issue of kind of unifying people's
experiences and then creating divergence
when you when you're putting together
the stories and when you editing the
films we mostly try to ground the films
in a very sort of simple under structure
I
I believe in having a very very strong
kind of engine sort of a very basic
story that is there even though we often
sort of disguise it with lots of ideas
and but I think to hold it all together
it really needs you know this this real
you know skeletal structure at the core
of it and then we work really really
hard to you know build that out with
kind of very traditional and you know
old-school ways of looking at story
structure we come both of us kind of you
know our big big student big students of
myth and looking at the kind of signpost
that people of stories that people have
been telling for thousands of years
it could be much longer than that that
we've been telling stories like that and
we've also often discussed about you
know there's some type of there's
something going on in that story
structure that we think that is you know
somehow you know just part of what we
are as humans if we get it when we're
very young or if we're born with it it's
definitely this part of the experience
the human experience that it is
definitely pain cultural and the
connections between that for all people
on the planet is you know something we
try to plug into
that's something actually that you've
been saying that it it poses the
question my mind for Jeff so your
research is actually looking at this
systemic kind of expectation of
narrative
so do you see do you think there are
brain networks that are there in place
to kind of primers for this kind of
narrative structure so there's a meme
floating around that we think in stories
and I find that attractive and dangerous
I'm really curious to hear what you guys
think about it I'm also struck that you
know if you're gonna have a big driving
engine that runs a whole movie it that
in this connects for the those who were
here yesterday so some of the data that
you already described that things that
happened you know 20 30 minutes ago in
the in the movie effect you're
processing of this moment now in it so I
wonder I mean do you think about okay
well what happened in their brains you
know 30 minutes ago that's gonna change
how this shot has to go we don't use the
word brains we usually talk about
emotion but yeah we're always thinking
about where the audience is and what
they've experienced and what they're
thinking there's usually always a I mean
there's always a theory of where the
camera is and why it's there I mean it
and it sometimes it's on a
scene-by-scene basis when you're making
those decisions but if you've really
done your work hopefully you're thinking
about it globally you know we definitely
had a theory in requiem for a dream when
we were doing that to start off wider
and move tighter and tighter as a sort
of to bring people deeper and deeper
into the subjectivity of the characters
and it was definitely something we were
playing with a lot was subjectivity and
objectivity in all my films probably the
least amount in Inoue which is sort of
more of a just sort of a great old story
we were telling objectively but yeah
we're always thinking about how we get
into an emotional state moment by moment
and how to bring as many people in the
audience with us so and what about this
I do you can make people do whatever you
want
you just packaged it up in a story even
characters or audience members audience
members to do whatever you want what do
you mean like so this is Heidi and I
think it's very powerful Peter Guber has
a book called tell de Winne that lays
out this idea and and and you see it in
so he's a film industry person you also
see it from scientists that you know we
think in narrative and therefore if you
want to persuade people or control them
or reach them you just you got to make
it a story and I like I said that really
attractive but also dangerous well I
think there's a truth to that I you know
absolutely these stories changed the
world you know like I kind of noticed
one when JFK sort of became the cultural
sort of conversation for a long time
it's sort of that was the big shift in
conspiracy theory kind of becoming
mainstream and you see that throughout I
think where films sort of change the way
people think I don't know if it's all
just if that's the only way to make an
impact but I do think that it's a very
powerful tool because I think you're
playing out you're you know you're
definitely riding along the subjective
experience and your research sort of
shows that of these characters you're
feeling what's going on in the
characters and you're playing out and I
used to always talk about Requiem as you
know when there was all the critique
early on on that film about what good is
it you know and and I was talking about
how tragedies are really not made in
American cinema at that time there was
really no tragedies and how it sort of
this dead art form that was like a big
part of literature and theatre for a
long time before that but it kind of
died with the Hollywood happy ending and
that there's a value to it in that you
know through the catharsis of those
characters you actually can apply that
stuff to your life and that stuff has
come back to me from different people
who that film
you know has influenced or you know
change their lives and stuff so I you
know I think I think you know that
definitely I think story I mean that's
that's the basis I think of story or at
least my imagination of the cavemen
telling stories back in the day they
were sort of you know they were giving
basically warning messages I think
that's kind of what Noah was about and
why it's been told for so many thousands
of years and all of these stories that
in the patterns we see in between all
the mythology they're all talking about
they're all giving lessons that people
are experiencing so that when it happens
in real life will be somewhat prepared
to deal with it